peu
[Musique]
on a quitté gages à 6h du matin
6 heures du matin on en est là à 9h05 je
crois qu'on est
fontainebleau ici un en est à
fontainebleau oui vous avez prévu une
heure d'arrivée
non non on a prévu pique nique surtout
je viens dans la banlieue ouest j'ai
quitté vers 6h30 je suis remonté le bio
9h 12h30 75 km si vous avez prévu une en
arriver là absolument absolument pas
compte tenu des informations précises
on ya pris son parti maintenant
reviendrait sans parti il ya les
embouteillages on s'arrête y en a pour
rôle
vous êtes aux nouvelles dans la voiture
pendant les embouteillages atteint les
monty vous tiens on écoute la radio puis
on discute avec ma belle mère
voilà je regarde les gens non mais la
radio les côtés beauchamp alors pourquoi
partir aujourd'hui pourquoi pas lundi
par exemple j'ai loué à l'hôtel mais je
me suis dit peut être que les autres
jours ça serait la même chose
banane on manque pour passer le temps ça
fait déjà un peu partie des vacances les
bouchons annonce a vendu beaucoup
est ce que pour vous les bouchons ça
fait déjà un peu partie des vacances
ouais ouais bien sûr
alors c'est agréable pas tout le temps
mais disons un petit peu le folklore
[Musique]